bien alors j'ai accueilli maintenant un
homme politique ah ah ouais et alors
c'est assez exceptionnel parce que c'est
dans cette émission soit toutes les
semaines
enfin toutes les semaines fait qu il ya
des émissions en soit des hommes
politiques
et alors c'est de plus en plus dure
parce qu'ils sont tous mis en examen et
alors on a trouvé un bon coup chez rcgt
pas mis en examen dont qu'il peut venir
ici s'appelle jean luc mélenchon
jean luc mélenchon bonsoir anne
parillaud donc aller olivier linda hardy
or jean luc mélenchon vous vous êtes
vais pas vous n'êtes pas de problème go
de quel point de vue pas du point de vue
judiciaire je dirais pas le grand soir
il veut dire en clair il n'y a plus
moyen de trouver dans paris avec le star
croisés pour les hommes de mon âge
j'aurais donc la mode est aux costards
balladur vous avez tous l'air d'un
berlingo dévoue le fermer ouais il faut
être heureux comme quelqu'un qui a 25
ans que je fais ce que je veux d'accord
il la couleur non non non j'en dans la
couleur en libye je vous demande de vous
voilà tout de suite bien jean-luc
mélenchon comme vous en connaissez pas
conforme à la dure salut c'est marrant
balladur fait flipper tout le monde tu
mets balladur tout le monde est là bien
jean-luc que vous êtes sénateur de
l'essonne
mais sérieuses et pas pour un sénateur
ou plutôt j'ai pas mal et sénateurs
j'imagine toujours des mecs comme ça
sénateurs butin était le plus jeune
sénateur de france en 86 oui oui parce
que jusqu'à 74 il fallait avoir 40 ans
pour être élu et alors ça a changé c'est
passé à 35
j'ai été élu pile poil 35 ans à moi vous
avez 35 ans il est où là j'en ai 40
c'est bon j'ai flippé un moment vraiment
j'ai 35 ans si je ressemble à ça mais
alors qu'est ce que tu veux dire à ces
travaux sont publiés
quant à lui ressembler non plus alors
tout va bien inutile alors bon vous êtes
l'état on va parler un peu de votre
carrière politique il faut dire quand
même c'était le premier en 91 a initié
un projet qui devenu le pacs après oui
c'était le cul qu'à l'époque
non moi ça s'appelait une équipe n'est
pas du tout moi j'ai appelé ça le
partenariat civil oublié mais que les
frères soit possible pour tout le monde
c'est pas simplement un mariage
homosexuel comme l'a été le pacs a
pressé les homosexuels qui m'ont donné
l'idée parce qu'on m'avait envoyé en 88
selah sue hallyday qui nous ont donné au
moins vous attendez vous allez voir
passer un petit moment un peu comme ça
donc on m'invite en 88 à une soirée ces
gais pour les libertés on ne voit là
pour faire la campagne de mitterrand
donc on m'avait dit parler des nouveaux
modes de vie alors je commence la vie
les jeunes tout ça je parle parle pas
trop mal et quand j'ai fini bon les gens
qui étaient là me disent vraiment ce que
vous dites c'est bien mais vous savez
c'est pas notre problème et il me
raconte ce qui se passe moi je n'avais
pas la moindre idée de ce à quoi elle
savait pas qu'il y avait ça quelle est
cette cruauté
quand il y en a un des deux qui meurent
de kish était dehors bref donc je me
suis dit je n'oublierai pas j'ai pas
oublié bien mais maintenant c'est vrai
on est capable de faire des choses bien
demain soir la joie qui est pas mis en
examen il fait des trucs d'ailleurs bien
alors là vous et xavier à écouter fait
pas ça fait pas croire qu'on sait que
c'est pas bien c'est un plat
attendez-vous les pourquoi mais je
voulais que je continue donc c'est bien
qu'on avait du tout je voulais me dire
nous avons répondu ok on avait invité je
viendrai il mal ces débats y est c'est
vrai que c'est bien faire de cette
histoire de montres là vous êtes au
courant
bah oui j'ai lu ça dans l'espace et
alors non j'ai pas et on lui reproche
d'avoir acheté le monde 250 mille balles
va avoir payé la moitié en liquide oui
si alors évidement médiane liquide
ah oui dit il il donne moi je crois que
c'est plutôt non moi je suis comme vous
je trouve ça fou il achète un avion
c'est vrai qu'on est un petit peu en
dehors de ça il faut être un petit peu
un moment donné faut être sérieux dans
un débat je comprends tout à fait ce que
ce que dit moi ce que je connais de lui
c'est la passion l'engagement un type
qui passe sa vie à sa guise ou je vous
répond mathieu histoire de moutons alors
je m'en fous bon ben c'est on va parler
de vous
parce que sa voisine merci pour les sous
titres si une émission bien tenu dites
moi donc j'ai commencé comme prof de
français en 74 est rentré à l'unef caen
77 au ps vous appréciez beaucoup donc là
l'organisation et la méthode de joxe et
avant vous avez été trotskiste avant
mais vous avez déclaré je ne pouvais pas
être communiste est bradé la révolution
dont vous étiez trotskiste ouais vous
étiez donc au pci c'est ça oui moi
j'étais trop de qui je veux dire ça me
fait plaisir vous me le dire parce que
ça fait maintenant un mois deux mois que
ça dure
on a pris comme ça toc toc un ou deux
visages de trotskistes oui on transforme
notre histoire notre jeunesse en une
histoire terrible d'un complot
moi je suis fier de ce que j'ai fait
d'accord j'en ai un magnifique souvenir
on savait bien jean-luc mélenchon que ça
c'est pas cher c'est une position dans
votre jeunesse vt trotskiste d'autres
ont été communiste d'autres mais ce
qu'on reproche aussi ses appels et
lamberti c'est à dire 7 ces gens qui
sont autour de pierre boussel alias
lambert et qui ont infiltré un petit peu
tous les rouages de la république
mais c'est du cinéma tout ça à chaque
génération
vous avez j'ai pas peur des mots une
élite humaine ces gens qui s'engagent
bon dans les années 60 c'était ceux qui
refusaient la guerre d'algérie ce qui
était pas communistes étaient tous ps
eut donc elles prennent les retrouver
des pssu partout bon dans les années 70
et début 80 bas tout le monde était
extrême gauche est normal dans dans
notre génération
donc ces gens là jusque là c'est après
il ya des réseaux et vous en trouver
partout et coûteux des rezzous tout me
fait rigoler on se connaît où on se
connaît pas on a passé commence une
affaire générationnel maintenant si
c'est si formidable d'avoir été à l'eau
ces ihu paix s'est enfin séparé pourquoi
je sais pas
veut pas reconnaître qu'il a été lui
peut-être parce qu'ils viendraient été
mais pas pour les questions et cadets
des gens qui ya quand même des gens qui
l'ont ils témoignent les hommes et
terrifiante et je n'ai pas vu les jeunes
éloignés ce que tout le monde témoigne
ans il ya plein de gens qui ont témoigné
en disant jospin il était responsable
d'une dynamique ce qui était une
structure de base dans le système
trotskiste et s'il avait même un surnom
un pseudo que c'était sur mon dieu un
blaze c'était michel et il ya des gens
qui l'ont vu payer ses cotisations
mais ils disent moi je n'étais pas là
que j'ai inventé non mais moi j'étais
j'étais responsable dans mon coin j'ai
rien vu de tout ça je jeu ça m'amuse
toujours un peu parce que ça ça
participe spis d'ambiance
fantasmagorique
tout d'un coup il ya un tas de gens qui
sera elle convient de dire quelque chose
ça tombe bien nous en avant les
présidentielles on joint l'utile à
l'agréable mois dans les sondages ce
soit négatif pour jospin d'avoir été
trop sinon je vais pas dire c'est
négatif trouve qu'il a on peut leur
souvent lui reproche d'avoir pris
strauss kahn comme ministre des finances
et des trains p d'être un peu trop à
droite
je trouve pas que ce soit négatif pour
lui le fait d'avoir été trop ce qui ça
prouve son attachement ça serait bien au
socialisme ça serait bien comme ça je me
sentirai mieux entourer hockey j'ose pas
on passe au chapitre suivant en 88 donc
déçus par la politique de rocard un peu
centriste vous fonder la nouvelle école
socialiste qui est devenue la gauche
socialiste en 91 avec new marais pas des
mois vous marrer avec marie thérèse
lienemann je viendrai nom marie noëlle
pas marie thérèse c'est le tissu cours
des fraises julien dray jean christophe
cambadélis dans la plus pure et dure
bonjour cambadélis non plus n'était pas
là n'étaient pas là complètement jamais
kamba il fait ses trucs
imaginons qu'il soit déjà à servir de
faire ce qu'on a à faire on peut pas
quand il était numéro deux du ps vous
êtes au psg numéro 2 oui oui mais c'est
un type bien cambadélis il travaillait
il serait bien pour un est nommé yves
lainé qui était un ancien du ps a non
seulement ils avaient un emploi fictif
m'ont plu c'était pour un mec qui était
du fn par dresser une c'est curieux
cette affaire
mais c'est marrant c'est comme philippe
sollers quand julie vous avez été mal
oui je dis ouais ouais ouais c'est vrai
c'est pas bien enfin événement dont on
vit quand on fait une connerie on peut
pas dire oui j'ai raison c'est pas bien
mais tout visiteur moi qui vivais avec
abords des lycées fait partie d'un parti
dont il est numéro 2 voilà je suis comme
vous je veux le journal je regarde moi
je connais un cambadélis dans le journal
j'en vois un autre
moi je connais un autre cambadélis
connaît un organisateur je connais un
orateur je connais un homme politique
engagé jusqu'au fond des tripes double
journal votre chose je suis comme vous
je me dis vraiment je comprends pas à
100 c'est parce que non seulement alors
j'attends et là bon il dans un mauvais
moment ce n'est peut-être pas le moment
pour moi de me présenter je vais
attendre un petit peu mais la belge est
quoi cette histoire
bah oui bien sûr parce que là il va être
condamné
j'en sais rien on va nous y avoir passé
pas moi je trouve que quand on a un
emploi fictif déjà c'est pas terrible
mais on les joue un ancien du fn qui
était au sac yves lainé il était en
hausse à lui bien comme ça mais j'ai lu
tout ça commence à pas trop la télé ce
marrante s'affaisser à ça fera écouter
pas trop parce que vous la regardez pas
se voir si ça j'aime mieux vous dire
qu'il se dit ouh là là on va déjà
beaucoup trop quoi pas croire on rigole
pas tous les jours - dernière question
quel prix je vous vous occupez de
monsieur à prémilhat parce que pour
l'instant l'homme et fait parler des
autres de 95 98 était secrétaire de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées vous avez
des infos particulière sur la vente des
frégates françaises à taïwan pour ces
femmes
je veux dire que c'est ce que non c'est
pas grave non j'en ai pas je suis pas
trop pour que l'on donne du matériel à
taiwan s'y loue pause interrogé l'homme
politique